some influencers now are doing deals
like michael jordan or lebron james
might do for a sneaker
so this person is sponsored by fitbit or
they're sponsored by
this clothing company and they get a 2
000
a month retainer to talk about it and
plus their affiliate link gets them 25
bucks per
whatever and they just have to hit a
certain threshold or something and so
the
the person who's providing the
relationship for the sponsorship says
okay can i make more than twelve
thousand dollars off of the relationship
with this influencers was on tiktok
and it seems to me to be pretty
authentic especially if you were doing
it
through your existing base do you have
people who are influencers already using
the product and sharing it for free
anyway now because i see sometimes that
comes up on my feed
oh yeah we have people sharing that we
have people reaching out we have ncaa
ncaa athletes who are trying to reach
out and say hey let's start to use that
platform but
definitely a lot of people are reaching
out and when they do like i said those
are the ones that end up being the best
partners we do have people that we reach
out to and other influencers that we
work with that we've also worked with in
the past but but i would say by by and
large the best
partners are people who are fit by users
all right
what's the plan to triple revenue this
year and next
how do you make that next jump and is it
getting easier
to make the jumps now that you have more
resources how has your life changed
because it's one thing to grow from six
thousand to twenty thousand a month or
twenty thousand to fifty thousand but
now you're starting to get to this
million
plus a month in revenue it is harder
to move the needle you have to take
bigger swings more money's at stake
maybe you talk to me a little bit about
how do you keep this level of growth up
and build out the team in order to do
that
yeah i think we have a ton of room to
grow with our existing
product and our plot and existing
platform base we have 225 000 paying
customers
and jason 125 000 paid customers
it's amazing congratulations yeah
definitely thank you but
we're not there yet and i think this
product can definitely grow to over a
mil just by continuing to improve the
product and giving our users a better
experience
and i think with that we just follow
right in line of calm which is fairly
well which has
probably millions of users at this point
subscribers yeah so i think
we keep doing what we do better and over
the next six months our roadmap
allows us to continue to build a better
and better product for our users
whether that's google i o who presented
us at google i o for their wear os app
their new watch app
or it's out apple wd wwdc who presented
us with their
you know apple watch and the always-on
feature that they're going to introduce
on is the new thing with the apple watch
where the screen's always on
exactly and you'll see your workout on
your watch even when you lower it so you
can get that information on your watch
all the time
and at wwdc apple introduced this
feature
uh using fitbot as the example so
amazing
is because that happened to calm early
on and we started just or zynga i
remember my friend mark pincus or uber
was included in some of those moments
and when you start getting asked by the
platforms to
do the special functionality that's when
you know you're in
uh really great shape now just talking
about the financing of a company like
this you've been incredibly capital
efficient
you've heard my term before pegasus i
think a lot of people
program have heard it pegasus to me is
defined as a company that's so
profitable
they can fly over rounds of funding
without diluting the cap table what this
basically means is
you are able to grow the business off of
revenues i believe i'm the
am i still the only major outside
investor in the company
yeah that's correct you're you're the
you're the main investor in football
and you've had many opportunities to
raise money i offered you money many
times
and i remember i was like hey maybe we
do a 10 million dollar round and
you just only wanted to raise a couple
of million and so
you've basically run this company with
only diluting ballpark 10 or 15 percent
is
is that a ballpark correct 15 maybe yeah
investors
what is your thinking now as the company
has gotten this big and the funding
environment has gotten so rich
and you continue to run a profitable
enterprise i believe your cash position
most months goes up rather than down
am i still correct on that yes i read
the updates
and it's really very similar it's like
deja vu all over again when i read the
comm
updates alex would send me the update
and i'd be like okay you're gonna raise
more money and they're like no
the cash you're seeing there is the cash
we're throwing off this business is
profitable
and i'd be like oh okay so the four
million dollars you're saying there is
money you made or we got that money from
ambassadors and i was like no that's
that bank account keeps growing because
what i will say is this and i'm actually
curious to hear your thoughts on this
jason and that's that
like i said the most compelling thing
for us right now
is to make sure that we take care of our
users and our team
and if we think about that we have a lot
of team members who have been working
really hard
and have been with us for a number of
years now and so if i were to think
about the most compelling reason to
raise
it would be to give these team members
an opportunity to see some liquidity in
their shares
sure so we could do 10 million
5 million in primary 5 million in
secondary
so that would be the way i would think
about it so then maybe try to raise 10
million at 160.
you earmark 5 million for primary to go
in
and then 5 million to buy secondary and
there's plenty of people who like to buy
that secondary and what would you do is
the investors coming in would either get
to buy one or the other the secondary
shares might be at a 10 discount to the
preferred shares
typically because they don't have the
same right set but anyway
it's pretty close and then when you or
sometimes they just go for the same
prices they're preferred if you have
some motivated buyer but then what you
do is when the investors come in you say
listen we're doing this dual thing
for every 10 000 for every million
dollars you put in you get half and half
or
whatever it is and the founders can
drive that i think that's another way to
get a deal closed like a big series b
which is this would be a this would be
your series a technically because you
really never did a
did we price the last round i'm curious
i can't remember the last time yes
so that was like a seed price seed round
and a big number
so if you call this a series a and you
could even raise 25 million and have 10
go to
secondary and 15 go to primary and the
reason to do it would be
it just gives you another two years of
runway and if something opportunistic
comes out you're not losing money so
just a war chest but if something
opportunistic came out like an
acquisition
we or adding more team members or you
saying to the team members
anybody who's been here for five years
can sell ten percent of their shares
you've been here four years you can sell
seven percent of your years three
years and under or three years you can
sell twenty percent of your shares
whatever and then
two years you can sell nothing only this
applies to people three years and above
so you did you get that kind of nice
longevity
kind of approach i think it's not a bad
idea i would think it's a smart idea
actually because
you do have people who've been there
over four years right around four years
is i think the mark for the longest
people
so yeah it is a great way to keep people
in the company
longer over the past few years everyone
has been talking about no code
and one of the first no code web app
tools was
bubble empowers people to design and
launch their own apps
marketplaces or tools without needing
coding skills or
pricey engineers bubble offers a digital
editor and cloud hosted platform
for as low as 29 a month users can build
pretty much
any complex web app from marketplaces to
social networks to sas tools and
more why is bubble so great for founders
because you can spend
10 times less on building out your mvp
bubble utilizes drag and drop
elements in their visual editor so users
can quickly and easily
build powerful apps go from idea to
launchable product in a matter of days
or weeks
not months and they handle all the
annoying stuff like deployment and
hosting
so you can focus on your product and
customers bubble has over 1 million
users worldwide and
enables over 1 billion in business
volume their founder and ceo emanuel was
on episode 1021
back in january of 2020 so you can check
that out if you want to learn more
and bubble is offering one month free on
any of their paid plans ranging from
their personal plan of 29
a month to their production plan of 529
a month but act best because they're
only offering this deal
for the first 500 redemptions head to
bubble dot io
slash twist and snag one of those 500
coupons